it's weird to be a robot in office but
it's just as weird to have to interact
with one you can't shake their hand you
can't grab a cup of coffee they might
fall over on you or freeze up while
you're talking about what robot
co-workers are going to become more and
more common in the near future so we all
need to learn how to get along after
living as a robot employee for a few
months here some etiquette tips I've
learned there you just have to set you
had something on here now my pleasure
first rules for humans with robot
coworkers
this machine is a physical extension of
your real coworker so don't do anything
to it that you can do to that person in
real life don't inappropriately touch a
robot when you pick up your coworker
without asking them know so don't do
that to their robot either also know no
shaking it pushing it or generally
touching it at all without asking don't
sneak up on a robot family so I'm
thinking about that story coworker
doesn't have eyes in the back of a robot
hand and she barely has her own vision
so don't approach her from behind and
start talking where are you at isn't it
over here move to the front where she
can see oh oh there you are okay okay
and launch into a face-to-face meeting
let York over for a little taller so
they're looking at your eyes and come at
your bill oh hey hey hey
sorry no no wrong zoomable rules for
robots ask for help when you need it but
don't be put there robot may get stuck
into Wi-Fi dead wrong it's microphone
and may go dead you may get lost or fall
over and
there's no such thing as pride ask for
help but don't force your co-workers to
become constant robot babysitter's thank
you
don't interrupt your remote robot may
have a slight lag causing you to
interrupt everyone heating calibrates we
don't alienate your humans rip for you
yes
hey Delilah oh sorry
don't let me up on here mates just as
it's rude for a human being the scans
finally behind somebody's desk watching
with a tight and listening to their
phone calls robots - to refrain from
this kind of creepiness since your robot
doesn't make much noise as you roll by
make a habit of saying hello to your
co-workers so they hear you approach me
come on a robot I mean I always sneak up
I always think it's louder than
you